- Dans l'île de Vancouver,
beaucoup d'intérêt en 2020,
ca couple célèbre y a élu
domicile pendant quelques mois.
Le prince Harry, la duchesse
Meghan Markle et leur fils,
Archie. Mais qui donc était
le mystérieux propriétaire de
la demeure temporaire duououple
princier?
Selon une voisine,
le nom du milliardaire russe
Yuri Milner circule depuis
des années.
Yuri Milner a fait fortune
à Silicon Valley. Il a été
un important actionnaire
de Facebook et de Twitter dans
le passé. Il a fondé une
des scientifiques lorsn n n gala
animé par de grandes vedettes.
Cette opulente résidence
de 100 millions $ américains
ititit qu'il possède aussi
ce méga-yacht de plus deAnAnAnA,
ce qu'il a publiquement nié.
Yuri Milner n'est pas un dese e,
mais une enquête du New York
Times et du Consortium
international des journalistes
qu'une partie des fonds qu'il a
investi dans Facebook provenait
de Gazprom, une
russe. Ils ont été versés par
l'entremise de Alicher Usmanov,t
sanctionné. Milner a aussi
reçu des millions de dollars
du Kremlin pour investir dans
Twitter par l'entr r r r r r r .
Milner affirme n'avoir reçu
Russie depuis 2011. Lorsque nous
l'avons contacté, son assistante
ni sa famille, ni des sociétés
qui lui eseseseses ne possèdent
le fameux manoir dans l'île de
Vancouver.
Au registre foncier, impossible
de trouver didididididididididie
étététététaire, mais nous avons
trouvé une piste dans les
Pandora Papers, cette fuite
de documents confidentiels
provenandidididididis fiscaux.
Le manoir est détenu par
aux îles Vierges britanniques,
JEMC Management Limited,
qui appartient à son tou
à une société des Bahamas,
elle-même administrée par une
Andromeda, s'appelait auparavant
la Fiducie Yuri Milner.
Selon l'un des documents
confidentiels, Yuri Milner
série de sociétés, dont JEMC
Management, la société liée
au manoir. Nous avons montrés s,
un enquêteur de la GRC à la
retraite.
PATRICE POITEVIN, cofondateur dg
Centre ccocococococococococococn
- Si on prend pour acquis que
les documents sont véridiques,
ce que ça démontre, c'est quentt
sur la propriété.
les résultats de notre enquêteue
sa fiducie a bel et bien acquis
le manoir de l'île de Vancouver
en 2013. a a a a a a a affirme
qu'il ne contrôle et ne
béné
y compris le Manoir au Canada,
depuis 2014, et que ce sont
caritatives qui en sont les
bénéficiaireononononononononse,
Milner admet aussi qu'une
fiducie qu'il a constituée
yayayayayayayayacht Andromeda,
mais il affirme que ni lui
ni sa famille ne sont
bénéficiaires ou affiliés
aux actifs de cette fiducie.
- C'est facile de mettre un nom
sur un morceau de papier, mais
pour racheter cette propriété
et qvevevevevevevevevente et
le revenu de cette propriété?
en Ukraine, le gouvernement
Trud'i'i'i'i'i'i'i'i'il allait
accélérer la mise sur pied
d'un registre des véritables
incorporées au fédéral.ELELELELe
ministre, min. Finances, Canada
- Je pense que vraiment, c
on n'a pas les données fiables
en ce qui concerne lesCaCaCaCaC.
- Le Canada perdra-t-il saréputs
investisseurs qui souhaitent
rester dans
Jusqu'à présent, Ottawa
et la plupart des pr
ont fait bien peu pour
s'attaquer à ce problème, mais
d'une plus grande transparence